một vụ nấu xong của lạc vụ gì chuyện Mỹ, ICE tại thành phố Minia Police đã làm dưới lên lạng sản phân nổ và được tệ chuyến các nước biễm tạm ngon.
Trong đối cảnh các tổ của anh đến bán và chính quyền bán Minnesotar được ra những mơ cả tráng lược.
Bố nấu xong xảy ra ngày 1 bởi thống mơ.
Bởi nạn nhân là Rguyên Nhi đi Kho Göt, bởi bởi tối, công dân Mỹ và lạm mẹ của một bệ trái sảo tuổi.
Bà bị bán chết khi người trong xe hơi trong lúc cả đặc vụ gì chuyện ICE, thực hiện một cuộc bố giáp gió bộ anh đối với miếng trên khai.
Các đặc vụ u're nhỏ đã nỗ lực mở của xe của bà vụ trước khi bà lạc đi và bị bán ở cửa lịch gần.
Chân dịch của một lực ICE tại bán Minnesotar được mơ cả, là lợn nhất từ trước tới này với khoảng 2 nghìn đến sự sau phở viện.
Hăng in người đã xuống đường biểu tình tại Minia Police, lông thời giao cuộc phản đối cuộc lăng sáng như vọc, chỉ có gồm chia thổ phy nèc sản dưới hình phố cá.
Chông khi một chừng anh những nổi điện quyết, ngọt vụ việc là hành động từ vẻ và cho rằng nằm vụ đã phản lúc quy trình nghiệp vụ.
Nhưng lại nông Minnesotar không tin vọc và phí trở Minia Police, bà bò lực lệ này.
Kui trách nhiệm cho chính quyền tổng phố đúng năng tròm vì trên khai lực lượng liên bán mà họ cho là không trở kết.
Khiển dưới trước Minnesotar và cuộc điều trai lịch bán Mỹ, FBE đang từ thành các cuộc điều trai dương dễ FV vụ lộ xung.